la montée des couleurs comme si vous y
étiez aux côtés du 26e régiment
d'infanterie de l'armée américaine
le temps d'un week-end les jardins du
château de Breteuil à Choisel se sont
transformés en camp militaire proposant
de véritables scènes de vie et de
démonstration aux visiteurs nous avons
décidé de présenter des choses un petit
peu
qui sortent de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
d'habitude le côté guerrier de la
reconstitution historique donc vous
allez voir notamment bien entendu des
armes des choses comme ça mais des
choses un petit peu plus
différentes à savoir ce qu'on appelle un
display de cuisine un poste de
commandement une tente pour les soldats
ainsi que le Dallas unique en France vu
que nous sommes les seuls à en avoir un
des pièces uniques et de toutes les
époques des soldats de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en remontant par les poilus de
14-18 ou encore la gare de napoléonienne
au-delà du folklore ce qui anime ses
passionnés c'est avant tout la
sauvegarde du patrimoine et le devoir de
mémoire nous avons pour but de faire de
l'histoire vivante et de recréer la vie
journalière du des grenadiers à pied de
la Garde impériale sous Napoléon 1er
mais avant d'intégrer la garde passage
obligatoire par le recrutement alors
demain matin est-ce que tu peux être là
à 6h
pour garde à vous de vos batoutes des
reconstitutions qui fascinent et
inspirent aussi bien les petits que les
grands j'ai bien gardé le souvenir de
tout ça et c'est bien qu'il y ait des
gens qui se déguisent comme ça je suis
passionné militaria quand je serai un
peu plus grand je commençais à faire de
la reconstitution dans le civil et quand
je serai plus grand dans le militaire
un bon dans l'histoire qui criera
peut-être quelques vocations